pope francis has just landed in iraq
where he's going to fulfill a
long-standing promise to become the
first pontiff to visit the country
the three-day visits is his first trip
outside italy since the pandemic began
he's going to be welcomed by the prime
minister in baghdad before meeting
president
bargham salah at the presidential palace
the head of the roman catholic church
says he's going as a pilgrim of peace
we're bringing you live pictures
from baghdad airport as the pope's
flight airbus a330
the flight a7 4000 has just arrived
in front of the red carpet you can see
the iraqi military
honor guard standing there i want to
bring in our correspondent simona
faulting who's outside the presidential
palace
in baghdad she's joining us live
this is clearly a very important visit
for the pope but it's also of course
very important
for the christians in iraq as well
[Music]
uh yes indeed they are seeing uh this
visit as something very important
something to give them hope
after years and decades really of uh
persecution that has resulted in a
significant decline
in their numbers before the us 2003
invasion there were over 1 million
christians here in iraq and that number
has dwindled in the past 17 years to
less
than 300 000 so this visit by pope
francis is really aiming to give them
hopes to encourage them
to remain in their ancient lands to
really sustain this
christian minority here but of course
the big question is
here is whether pope francis will focus
on the spiritual aspects of this visit
on the spiritual aspects of this visit
or whether he will actually tackle
some of the policy issues which are
resulting uh in the persecution
oppression of christians
one of those issues for example is the
is the presence of military groups
in the nineveh plains which is a home to
many christians some of these armed
groups that are present there have
prevented the returns of christians
who are who were displayed by the latest
war against iceland this is something
that
organizations that deal with minority
rights have demanded the pope to tackle
when he meets the president later here
at the presidential palace they want him
to
bring up these difficult topics they
want him to actually
you know mention these recommendations
to try to actually result in some
political change but of course this will
be very difficult because the problems
afflicting the christian community
today are problems that are afflicting
all of iraq really it is
uh the challenges for the states to
control the weapons in the hand of
formal security forces it is
there is the rule of law it is the
respect for human rights it's not just
iraq's christians that are
suffering from these issues it is iraq
as a country as a whole and the
government has really
struggled to for example control
some of the armed groups that have been
accused of perpetrating human rights
abuses among others against the
christian communities
and these kind of issues will of course
be
something that the pope may not be able
to bring up and certainly that would be
very difficult
for the government here to resolve but
there is definitely a lot of hope a lot
of expectations
which merely highlights the level of
needs in this country
just as you're talking there's someone
who are watching our live pictures from
baghdad airport as i say the steps have
just been moved up to the door
of the aircraft which is currently
closed we're waiting for the
preparations for that to open
uh any moment we've also earlier on and
certainly in the last hour or so seen
crowds of people lining the streets
um waiting for the the pope to arrive
but one of the problems is going to be
that the pope is not going to be able to
meet
large crowds of people because of the
uptick in coronavirus
in iraq so security and safety is
clearly going to be important here
yes indeed the security is really
something that
has been of course a big challenge for
authorities here because this is a
country that is
facing many problems on that front uh
there is the coronavirus pandemic which
you mentioned we're currently having
around
5000 new cases uh per day uh there is of
course still a threat by isil there are
sleeper cells across the country which
have
uh launched repeated attacks against
security forces we've had a pretty
sizable suicide bombings here bombing
here in the capital in january which
claimed
dozens of lives and then there are also
frequent rocket attacks that are
targeting
uh especially u.s interests here in iraq
the last rocket attack happened
uh just two days ago and claimed the
life of one
uh u.s civilian contractor in western on
bar so
there are enormous challenges for the
security forces here to really ensure
that
this uh itinerary by the pope which just
spans
thousands of kilometers going from
baghdad to southern iraq and then
to northern iraq is properly secured
that there is no potential security
breach
that could somehow hamper this journey
and of course
the security forces are very high alert
they have blocked off
the green zone which is um this
fortified area
area in baghdad which houses a lot of
the government institutions
uh as well as the united nations and
embassies that
space has been completely closed off uh
to
uh enable quick and safe passage for the
pope and of course security forces have
also
been deployed throughout the city we've
seen very heavy security presence
throughout
checkpoints being set up to search cars
to check
badges because only people with special
badges are allowed to be even out on the
street today
because there is a curfew in place
friday saturday and sunday the exact
days when the pope is
traveling around to prevent the movement
of people to prevent the movement of
cars and really to reduce the number of
people
who will come out uh to greet him which
is certainly a little bit
counterintuitive for the christian
community because they certainly want to
get out to the streets they want to see
him
they want to greet him and really get
the inspiration from this visit and that
may be difficult
for many people because the number of
spaces that have been allocated
at each and every venue that he visits
are relatively
limited only a small number of people
will be able to attend
and that is of course both for security
reasons but also
to try to reduce the number of new covet
cases
that we have seen in the country we're
just seeing again
pictures from the uh aircraft the al
italia aircraft which is waiting on the
air
the apron at baghdad airport we can see
the pope standing at the
top of the steps they are waiting to uh
being greeted by
an official there there are also uh
crowds of well-wishers who are clearly
and officials who are waiting at the
bottom of the
um the steps what impact is the pope's
visit
do you think going to have on the future
of
christians in iraq is there a confidence
that they're standing in the country
is going to be in any way improved by
this visit
well i think from his side there is
certainly hope that he wants to
encourage them to stay because the way
we have seen the numbers of christians
decline
over the past few years uh it really
looks as though this community is
disappearing i recently a few months ago
i spoke to
a priest in the northern town of bartela
which used to be
a majority christian town but which has
in recent years
become majority muslim and that priest
was telling me look
i will stay he was an elderly man but he
said i cannot force the new generation
to stay they have options to emigrate
abroad
to start new and better lives abroad to
be free to be able to practice their
religion safely
and of course that is a very fair demand
of this christian community
but on the other hand there are many who
feel like no this is my homeland
i want to stay here i want to try to
preserve this ancient heritage of ours
to make sure that this community endures
and these are the people that the pope
really
wants to reach out to he wants to
encourage them to persevere
to stay in iraq so that this minority
doesn't completely vanish but
as i mentioned before that will take
some very very concrete policy measures
that would need to be implemented
we've actually seen a statement come up
by a group of 46
ngos that work on minority rights and
they have listed
a number of recommendations that they
would like the pope
to raise with iraq's leaders while he is
here
and among those recommendations are for
example
reparations for victims of genocide
as a result of isil they're also want
justice for victims who have suffered
from the war with isil
they want political and security
arrangements that will protect
ethno-religious
minorities and of course what they're
alluding to is the presence of armed
groups that are officially
part of the state's security
infrastructure but it also
did a lot of times act outside of the
chain of command and
those groups are uh partly blamed for
persecuting uh
christians in the north i actually
interviewed one of the commanders of
these groups who has been recently
sanctioned by
the united states his name is wad kado
he leads the 30th brigade
of the popular mobilization forces in
bartela which is a town in the north
and he has been sanctioned for uh so to
say
preventing christians from returning to
that town so
whether or not christians in iraq feel
that they can actually have a tangible
political change as a result of this
visit it will really depend on the
state's ability
to try to assert rule of law to try to
really
strengthen its institution and that is
something that of course is way beyond
the pope's ability this is something
that will
need years and decades of state building
nevertheless i mean the pope is
uh certainly in religious terms is going
to be meeting with
uh i believe there's an inter-religious
meeting um
at us the ancient site of ur which is
scheduled i believe for saturday but he
is going to be meeting
a wide variety of religious leaders
within iraq and that is significant as
well isn't it because iraq
is a country where several religious
religious followings are represented
but not only in the street but also of
course in parliament as well and
politically
that is correct and perhaps the the most
significant personality he will be
meeting
is grant ayatollah al-sistani who is
basically the religious authority of
shia muslims
here in iraq he will be meeting him
tomorrow in najaf
and the idea of that meeting is really
to uh
to foster tolerance and coexistence
between
uh the religions that is certainly
expected to be a very significant uh
meeting it is not
exactly certain what will come out of it
whether there will be any kind of
official agreement that will be signed
between the two sides or some kind of
joint statement that will be made but
that meeting very much underlines uh the
theme of this visit which is
you are all brothers which is of course
a verse from the bible
and the pope really wants to underline
the commonalities between the three
abrahamic religions which are
judaism christianity and islam he wants
to really
emphasize the similarities between these
faiths rather than the differences
hoping that
that that his visit can somehow reset
relations that it can somehow be the
beginning
of a new start and that is of course why
he's also going to ur which is
in southern iraq in the province of the
car
there he will be holding an interfaith
dialogue with
muslim leaders to try to again emphasize
the commonalities because of course
ur is thought to be the birthplace of
abraham the patriarch
of the three monotheistic faiths it is
there where he was supposed to
have been born before he received the
call as the bible goes from god to
migrate
to the promised land and of course he's
somebody who is very important for
christians jews and muslims alike for
muslims he is known as prophet ibrahim
he is the one
who is celebrated during the islamic
holiday of idalhatta to honor his
sacrifice and he's also
who is thought to have built the kaaba
in mecca in saudi arabia which is of
course
one of the main pilgrimage the main
pilgrimage site
for muslims so in visiting sites like
these uh in
or the pope is really honoring the the
heritage and the
and the memory of of christians in iraq
but
also hoping that he can somehow set a
new foundation that
he can perhaps uh even incentivize
christian to come
christians to come to iraq as a as part
of a pilgrimage to visit for example
abraham's house uh in ur so from a
spiritual
perspective this visit is really hugely
important but the question again
is will it result in any kind of real
policy changes on the ground that will
change the relations
uh between muslims and christians we're
just seeing pictures there the inside of
the uh the airport now the purpose
has moved inside he's being flanked by
people what appeared to be traditional
dress who are
appear to be singing i believe as he
walks up the the aisle
when you've been talking to people in
baghdad simona is there an indication
uh from non-christians about how
important they regard this visit or is
this something that is
not as high a priority for people who
are not christians
well most people that i have spoken have
been
really excited about this visit because
it's not just
important for the christians it also in
a way shows that iraq is perhaps
stable enough to welcome the pope we
have seen very few
western heads of state or important
dignitaries visit this country precisely
because it is
associated with instability with war so
just the very fact that the pope is
coming to iraq that he is trusting
the iraqi state to protect him that he
feels comfortable
going not just to the airport into the
green zone but outside the green zone to
move around across baghdad to move
around across
iraq it is in a way very encouraging to
ordinary iraqis not just christians
that perhaps this is a new page for iraq
but perhaps
this is a sign that things are perhaps
improving so
in general they have very much welcomed
him but of course on the other hand
there are also a lot of
expectations with regard to what he can
achieve for
uh for muslims a lot of people have been
actually
posting messages on social media
demanding
that the pope visit certain places
because they know that
the places that he has visited they have
received
more attention from the government
lately for example roads have been
paved in ur leading up to the
archaeological site that he
will visit roads have been cleaned and
repaired
so there is in a way some belief that
only
the places that the pope will visit will
receive attention
from the government so of course even
even non-christians even muslims have a
lot of expectations tied to
this visit that it will usher uh in some
improvement in their lives
simone thank you very much indeed simona
14 talking to us
from baghdad as pope francis arrives at
baghdad airport at the start of a
three-day visit to the country it's the
first ever papal visit
to the country his first international
trip since the start of the pandemic
while yona dam khanna is head of iraq's
christian al-rafi dain parliamentary
block and he says this is
a historic moment for christians in iraq
that almost two thousand years later the
pope of vatican visit us here in such
difficult situation
and iraq is suffering from very
different issues
pandemic and the economical and and
everything and even conflicts in the
region
between american iran and many many
other issues so we are very happy and
welcoming his holiness
that we hope that he he for sure he is
bringing the
the the message of peace and love and
forgiveness jesus
message and uh and his visit will have
many many positive reflects on on iraqi
society and in the region and globally
as well
because uh as as you know the
the the reflect and the effect of the
isis and the al-qaeda
crimes against humanity against people
here
reflect very negatively on the islamic
image in europe and america and
everywhere
so his visit to our religious leaders in
iraq gives very very good positive
reflect
and bring down a bit the islamophobia in
europe and america and western
societies